Gilbert Gottfried is dead
I was shocked to hear I had no idea and
I have so many Gilbert memories that I
can share with you I always loved having
Gilbert on the show
I'm reading this Gilbert was on the show
122 times oh yeah he was on a lot I
didn't know 122. I wouldn't have guessed
a hundred but no yeah I don't think
we've been on the show no 122 times
uh Gilbert started doing stand-up when
he was just 15 years old which always
blew my mind because Gilbert was such
off you know from what I knew he was
very timid guy very kind of
Shy Guy and the idea that he would quit
school and become a comedian at 15 just
didn't fit with you're like where did he
find the strength
to do that and he did well and he landed
a spot on Saturday Night Live when he
was 25 years old well I'll play you this
clip this is a clip of Gilbert talking
about how he didn't fit in on Saturday
Night Live I hated the writers the
writers hated me and to show it why
there was one sketch they wrote that
takes place at a funeral and I was the
body in the carpet why but why didn't
you like why did you even bother
auditioning for Saturday love God knows
and then it was it was weird because I I
read other people's interviews about
auditioning for that yeah where they
said they were terrified and they hated
everyone else in the room and it was
just driving them nuts and I remember
when I auditioned I was like
I didn't even think about it I was there
I wasn't even you didn't care yeah yeah
it didn't strike me as anything I
auditioned they brought me back and I
auditioned again and then when they
announced to me oh you got the part it
also wasn't like you you weren't moved
by it yeah yeah that was Gilbert I mean
not not much moved him one of the um
early appearances on our show it was so
great we started messing with callers
right away we put we put them back on
hold constantly one of the callers got
pissed off and Gilbert just kept talking
over a second what I'm saying is that
yes
yeah this is a great drop that Gilbert's
responsible for we had Beetlejuice on
one time and I was trying to impress
Beetlejuice with who Gilbert Godfrey was
and uh Beetlejuice was having none of it
I tried to give all of Gilbert's
credentials
and Beetlejuice was just in a bad mood
and he did not like Gilbert and Gilbert
got into it with Beetle you obviously
have seen Problem Child
I have a problem child too I've never
seen that I never will and that's three
that was on television Aladdin go figure
yeah hey did you play a parrot yes I was
in Paris did you ever see Aladdin never
did I never will
Gilbert worked with Eddie Murphy wow go
for him
[Laughter]
well good for me or goof for Eddie
for you
Gilbert was the quickest uh human being
on the planet when he would do Dracula
God freed on our show I you know I would
say to him Gilbert just do Dracula
Godfrey didn't you know you couldn't
tell if he wanted to do Dracula godfreed
he do Dracula Godfrey and I even said to
him you would be a hit on on any
um sketch if you just did Dracula
Gottfried yeah but he didn't care but it
was so good
your legs open
I found you to spread your legs open now
and give me your cluey
I want your clue y
Now
give me her cloaky my favorite scene is
uh it's from that Old Dracula movie
listen to them the children of the night
but music they make
a spider spinning his web for an
unverified
if God is the life Mr rainfield
wow see that kind of Comedy only comes
from a lonely childhood where you just
sat in front of the TV and studied these
things you could have probably done the
whole script you know he knew these long
monologues and I loved his Rabbi Godfrey
character he told me um this is this is
the origin of it this is him telling me
how he came up with it then when they
weren't singing then the voice would
take on this weird accent that I wasn't
Jewish and wasn't he it's like when we
sit here today
[Music]
among star beloved relatives that's like
Dracula yes
our friends and our acquaintances
through life do you think they spoke
that way because uh by speaking slowly
they could think of the next thing yeah
exactly right and then they would break
into songs yeah and that would make you
laugh yes yes and so everyone please
stand me
[Music]
help me
at least let you sit down while you're
listening to that yes then everyone be
seated
for the rest of it now stand again
it's like an aerobic exercise
that's so naturally funny uh yeah
Gilbert would tell me stuff like yeah I
didn't graduate high school I'd leave
the house every morning I'd go to the
library instead and then ended up
pursuing stand-up comedy you're like
that's a Ball's move for a young kid and
uh oh and the other thing that he did is
um Groucho Marx yes most people who do
an impression of Groucho Marx would do
an impression of him as a Young Man the
Brilliance of Gilbert was
his impression was when Groucho was old
and senile and I could just picture a
young Gilbert Gottfried tuning into the
Dick Cavett Show and being absolutely
mesmerized by old Groucho Marx and
studying him and then coming up with
this routine
and it was just uh it was so good it was
like Groucho mugs when he used to go on
Dick Cavett I used to work with Chico
yeah
and we worked with Margaret romance who
was a beautiful actress right and we
like the WC feels Harper was named sapo
because she played The Hub and few
people knew that they call me Groucho of
course they said that I had a grocery
attitude
it was great I remember watching those
shows and old Groucho would cook because
I loved Groucho Marx but when old
Groucho would come out you go what the
[ __ ] so Gilbert picked up on that it was
great and um and then he tells a great
Sir Gilbert did a great Jerry Seinfeld
impression but he told me that uh Jerry
hated it and uh this is him telling that
story a lot of times I'd be on stage and
it would be like the waitresses and
other comics and staff would run in and
be laughing in the back in the audience
would be scratching their heads and
Seinfeld wasn't known at all back then
it was just another comic there and I
would start you know going up on stage
going
why do they say hello why isn't it hell
hi
100 people wish you was on our feet
why don't they wear gloves on their feet
and and Seinfeld would would stay out in
the bar because he was pissed yeah yes
he would walk he'd Pace people he would
Pace back and forth and go
that doesn't sound anything like me
what does she think I'm talking to sing
song voice I talk perfectly normal all
right God what a talent and uh also
after the whole thing went down with the
Aflac duck Gilbert had made all the
tsunami jokes and he lost being you know
he lost out on being the Affleck duck
and the world seemed to be coming down
on him he started telling me about how
he had to apologize and I don't think
Gilbert ever wanted to apologize he
never apologized for any joke he told
and that was his attitude about comedy
that no joke was off limits
and uh he came on the show and then
immediately admitted that the whole
apology was written for him
that he really had nothing to do with it
here he is uh confessing I'll be
perfectly honest that was like out of
the machine you know apology uh 176.
okay yeah here it is I sincerely
apologize to anyone who was offended by
my attempt at humor regarding the
tragedy in Japan yes it was I meant no
disrespect and my thoughts are with the
victims and their families were your
thoughts really with the victims
anything about this that is true all
right don't people know your thoughts
are only on you and and how to say yeah
well it's kind of like when Mike Tyson
uh has an apology or something released
to the Press right and it's so eloquent
have you made a tsunami joke since now
that I mean you are fired from Aflac you
might as well yeah I made a couple
of other right so your thoughts are
normal
oh I sent out a Twitter on Hitler's
birthday right yeah we could tell
stories all day about Gilbert we got
enough of them but I have a really fun
place in my heart for Gilbert I thought
uh he was great he was always funny
yeah he was terrific really terrific and
he was a master of his craft